-Welcome back to "Late Night".
It's December, a time
for holiday decorations,
and here to talk to us about her
favorite decoration of all
is one of our writers,
Amber Ruffin, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ It was December 25th
a couple years ago ♪
♪ I walked into a Walgreens ♪
♪ And the lights
were way down low ♪
♪ I needed a last-minute gift ♪
♪ I walked into aisle three ♪
♪ A man was playing music,
he was staring right at me ♪
♪ His melody made my body hot ♪
♪ It warmed my heart of stone ♪
♪ I fell in love
that winter night ♪
♪ When Santa played
the saxophone ♪
[ Jazzy version of
"Jingle Bells" plays ]
♪ The way he play his sexy song,
it made me want to dance ♪
♪ His music made me want to get
him out his big, red pants ♪
♪ We fell in love
in an instant ♪
♪ Two adults ready to bone ♪
♪ I was forever changed
that night ♪
♪ When Santa played
the saxophone ♪
[ Jazzy version of
"Jingle Bells" plays ]
♪ It was so hot, so passionate ♪
♪ The way he played
his jazzy set ♪
♪ I knew if I stayed silent,
I would die with the regret ♪
♪ Santa, I love you ♪
♪ Just one night with me,
it would change your life ♪
♪ I got a little closer,
and I saw he had a wife ♪
♪ He remains the hottest man
that I have ever known ♪
♪ But it was never meant to be ♪
♪ When Santa played
the saxophone ♪
[ Jazzy version of
"Jingle Bells" plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Amber Ruffin, everybody!
Check out
a new Christmas episode
of "The Amber Ruffin Show"
this Friday on Peacock.
Hey, wait, wait, wait.
You guys want to hear
a true story?
-Yeah!
-Yeah.
-Amber, today, comes
in the dressing room,
and says, "You want to hear
something funny?
I wrote that for
'The Amber Ruffin Show',
but the head writer
said it was too dumb."
[ Laughter ]
-And she was right.
-That's like, "Merry Christmas,
Dad, I don't want this."
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ] Amber Ruffin,
everybody!
We'll be right back with more
"Late Night"!